رجل نحيل بملامح قاسيه تتصدر صوره مجلات
المال والاعمال في اليابان ويتخذ اسما
كبيرا في نادي المليارديريه هذا الرجل
السبعيني الذي يتربع على قائمه اغنى
الاشخاص في بلده هو التداشي صاحب السبعه
والثلاثين مليارا ونصف المليار دولار فما
سر هذه الثروه ولد تاداشي ياني في عام
1949 في محافظه ياما غوتشي اليابانيه وفي
بلده اوبي التي اشتهرت بحرفه التعدين لكن
والديه كان يديران متجرا للملابس لم يرغب
تاداشي في الالتحاق بمشروع العائله فدرس
الاقتصاد والسياسه بالجامعه حيث وصف نفسه
انذاك بالشاب الكسول الذي لا يحب العمل
ويمضي وقته في اللعب الماجوج والباتشينكو
بعد تخرجه في عام
1971 عمل تاداش لفتره وجيزه في بيع ادوات
المطبخ والملابس الرجاليه في سلسله سوبر
ماركت قبل ان يستقيل وينضم على مضاد الى
متجر والده حيث كان يبيع البدل وربطات
العنق في عام
اصبحت داش رئيسا لسلسله ملابس والده التي
تضم 22 متجرا وافتتح متجرا جديدا في
هيروشيما تحت اسم متجر الملابس الفريد
الذي حمل لاحقا اسم يوني كلو ثم غير اسم
شركه والده في عام
1991 من اوغوري شوجي الى فاستري تيلينج في
غضون 10 سنوات فقط تحول المتجر الجديد الى
عشرات المتاجر الاخرى كما تم طرح الشركه
للاكتتاب العام سنه
1994 ما اسهم في تطوير السلسله التي اصبحت
لها فروع في جميع انحاء البلاد بين عامي
و2018 عندما افتتحت يونيكلو متاجر بمعدل
نحو متجر واحد اسبوعيا قفز صافي ثروه
تاداشي من خمسه عشر مليارا و500 مليون
دولار الى 24 مليار دولار وفي عام 2018 تم
ادراجه كواحدا من اكثر 500 شخص نفوذه في
صناعه الازياء من قبل
نجحت تاداش ايضا في تنميه اعماله من خلال
عمليات الاستحواذ على علامات تجاريه اصغر
مثل كومتوا ديكوتينيورز وامريكانز 3
وغيرها كما استطاع ان يحول شركه فاستري
تيلينج الامبراطوريه لبيع الملابس
بالتجزئه لم تشمل فقط شركه يونيكلو بل
وعلامات تجاريه اخرى مثل فاستري تيلينكثري
وهيل مودلانج وجيب لاند وجيو
في عام 2022 سجلت الشركه ارباحا صافيه
قدرها مليار و200 مليون دولار وايرادات
قدرها 17 مليار دولار لسنه الماليه
المنتهيه لتدفع باسم تاداشي الى تصدر
قائمه الاغنياء في اليابان مع ثروه تقدر
بنحو 37 مليارا و500 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]